herzlich willkommen in meine taten welt
heute gibt es von mir ein grundrezept
ich werde euch nämlich das grundrezept
für den biskuit teig verraten
mit diesem rezept könnt ihr verschiedene
torten backen könnte aber auch zum
beispiel bis mitrollen herstellen
die mengenangaben beziehen sich jetzt
auf einer 26 cm springform das heißt für
so eine standardgröße ihr könnt wenn ihr
zum beispiel biskuitrolle machen wollt
einfach das rezept halbieren und bei
allen anderen größen einfach hoch oder
runter rechnen
ich zeige euch jetzt erst einmal sie zu
taten ihr braucht sechs eier in größe m
sechs esslöffel heißes wasser 200 gramm
zucker eine packung vanillezucker oder
einen esslöffel selbstgemachten
vanillezucker 100 gramm mehl 100 com
speisestärke einen teelöffel backpulver
und je nachdem ob ihres hellen oder
dunklen biscuit machen wollt 25 gramm
kakao oder 25 g speisestärke ich möchte
jetzt heute dunklen biscuit herstellen
deswegen brauche ich diese speisestärke
nicht sondern verwendet 25 gramm cacau
bei der zubereitung gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten wie man den teig
herstellen kann
es gibt die klassische variante bei der
man die eier trend nach eigelb und
eiweiß und sie dann getrennt voneinander
aufschlägt oder so ihr macht so wie ich
das geht nämlich viel einfacher viel
schneller und viel effektiver ihr könnt
einfach die eier mit dem zucker
aufschlagen und später die trockenen
zutaten einfach noch dazu rühren
hierbei ist besonders wichtig dass die
eier zimmertemperatur haben oder ihr
eben dieses heiße wasser einfügt und
dann ganz lange schlag also das geht
wirklich so etwa fünf bis sechs minuten
bis dieser masse richtig locker wird und
damit ihr natürlich wissen wie das genau
geht zeige ich euch jetzt die
zubereitung im
schluss jetzt an den teig wird möchte
ich nicht die backform vorbereiten
wie gesagt verwende ich eine 26 cm
springform die lege ich jetzt mit
backpapier auslegen und entspannen und
dann scheide ich das drumherum ihrig
den bogen auch einfach einfetten und
behle
aber die ränder dürfte in die maße
einfetten da muss nämlich der viscotec
daran haften und kann so am rand entlang
hochklettern
auch bei rührteig hätte ich die ränder
nie ein damit der teig schön hoch geht
unter haften bleibt
das stelle ich jetzt kurz zur seite
und wenn es den teig vorbereiten hier
kommen jetzt einfach alle eier rhein
noch einen esslöffel heißes wasser also
hier insgesamt sechs esslöffel dann
werde ich das jetzt kurz berühren lassen
und nach und nach den zucker dazugeben
und den vanillezucker und lasst es doch
schön weiß schaumig aufschlagen
wenn die eier masse dann genug volumen
habt könnt ihr die maschine ausschalten
dann werden die trockenen zutaten
miteinander verrührt und gleich auch
gesiebt
so verhindert ihr einfach dass ihr
später klümpchen im teil kraft und dann
kommen die zutaten hier einfach rein und
das früher ich jetzt ganz kurz auf
niedrigster stufe mit dem unterheben
dauert es nämlich zu lange
wenn das nicht ganz gut geht dann mit
dem teig scheibe einfach nachhelfen
ihr dürft jetzt niemals diesem rührer
hier am rand abklopfen
da klopft ihr dann nämlich nur die ganze
luft aus dem teig wieder heraus die ihr
vorher so mühsam eingeschlagen hat hier
einfach von außen nach innen schöne
unterhalten
wenn ihr das arbeit habt kommt so
einfach in euro vorbereitete springform
ihr könnt den teig jetzt wenn ihr später
ein motiv torte draus machen wollt
isoliert backen
das heißt ihr könnt dann die backform
noch schön mit backpapier auskleiden und
außen rum diesen hitzeschutz mit
alufolie und küchenrolle machen das
hatte ich euch mal in meinem bananen
rührkuchen video gezeigt aber wenn ihr
eine ganz normale torte machen wollt
dann könnt ihr das einfach so machen und
hier könnt ihr jetzt den teig etwas bis
zum rand streichen
das hilft später einfach dass er gleich
wieder aufgeht man dann schon etwas teig
am rand haftet den teig werde ich jetzt
bei 175 grad ober unterhitze backen und
dann sage ich euch auch wie lange er
gebraucht hatte im vorfeld kann ich euch
das kann ich sagen mein biskuitteig hat
insgesamt 40 minuten gebacken
das sieht jetzt so aus ich habe jetzt
fünf minuten hier drin abkühlen lassen
ihr könnt auch ganz gut sehen das eher
gleichmäßig hoch gebacken ist also schön
glatt
der hatte macht der bug zeitzonen hubl
aber das legt sich dann zum glück
jetzt gehe ich hier einmal außen rum
öffne dich springform dann lege ich hier
so ein auskühlen gitter drauf und kann
das einmal stürzen und so kann man bis
ganz schön abkühlen
damit der bizkit beim abkühlen nicht
austrocknet legt die da am besten ein
feuchtes küchentuch drüber
ich habe jetzt keinen geschirrtuch
deswegen mache ich das jetzt mit
küchenrolle bizkit teilt nämlich dazu
schnell trocken zu werden und zur könnte
dem entgegenwirken so bleibt kuchen
schön saftig und wer will kann dann zum
beispiel noch etwas rum oder andere
leckere so darüber geben und den biss
gezeigt etwas passieren
mein bis geteilt ist abgekühlt und ihr
könnt ihr jetzt ganz normal weiter
verwenden das heißt ihr könnt jetzt zum
beispiel in der mitte durchschneiden der
creme einfüllen obendrauf mit creme
bestreichen und dann in den kühlschrank
geben oder ihr schneidet ihn nicht durch
sondern packt eine creme und früchte
drauf also je nachdem wie ich ihn jetzt
weiter verarbeiten wollte ich finde
jetzt kurz noch einmal zu stürzen
aufpassen hier klebt immer mal wieder
ich möchte den teig jetzt einfrieren
da ich ihn heute nicht mehr weiter
verwenden möchte und werde ihn jetzt
vorher einmal durchschneiden
da zusätzlichen einfach auf sondern
dreht immer setzte dann das messer
hiermit ich an und fahre einmal draußen
herum
da hab ich jetzt einfach eine schicht
backpapier 1 6 der deckel wieder drauf
und dann hab ich denn jetzt schön in
alufolie und in einer gefriertruhe
wenig denn bis geteilten eingefahren
habt könnt ihr ihn so etwa drei monate
lagern länger würde ich ihn nicht lang
da er dann an geschmack verliert und
etwas nach tiefkühltruhe schmeckt und
wenn ihr ihn dann wieder auftauchen
möchte
lass dir jeder am besten bei
zimmertemperatur wieder auf
normaltemperatur kommen und könnten dann
wie gewohnt weiter verwenden wenn es
etwas schneller gehen soll könnte ihn
auch ganz kurz im ofen aufbacken da
würde ich allerdings etwas aufpassen da
er sonst etwas trocken wirken kann
dann wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken wünsche euch eine schöne zeit
und bis zum nächsten mal tschüss